damas précédente vidéo je parlais de
nietzsche en expliquant que la
philosophie de nietzsche et est basé sur
un anti dualisme lentilles dualisme ça
veut dire
l'opposition à toutes les pensées qui
établissent des distinctions
conceptuelle entre des des couples de
contraire d'opposer tels que par exemple
le vrai le faux le bien et le mal que
nietzsche associé à la philosophie du
ressentiment
cette philosophie qui exprimait une
perte de l'unité originel et de la
volonté puissance qui caractérise le
réel et la vie puisque la volonté de
puissance est au delà de tous les
dualismes et au delà de toutes les
oppositions
j'ai eu l'occasion de rappeler que l'un
des représentants principaux de cette
pensée dualiste avait été platon platon
disciple de socrate platon philosophes
grecs de l'antiquité classique et j'ai
souhaité à travers cette nouvelle vidéo
revenir un petit peu sur la pensée de
platon
donc je précise tout de suite que cette
vidéo ne sera pas un exposé exhaustif et
systématique de la pensée de platon le
format de cette vidéo de ne le permets
de toute façon pas et ce n'est pas mon
objet puisque je pense que j'aurai
l'occasion de faire d'autres vidéos par
la suite qui viendront compléter celles
ci mais je souhaiterais quand même
essayer de revenir sur l'un des aspects
de la pensée de platon qui me semble
être heureux
l'aspect dominant l'aspect principal
celui dont découlent
l'ensemble de ces considérations quand
je parle de l'aspect principal je veux
parler de sa métaphysique la
métaphysique de platon n'est pas simple
d'accès n'est de compréhension elle
repose sur un dualisme que je vais
tenter il expliqué pour commencer de
même que chez schopenhauer platon
considéré que la réalité sensible la
réalité avec laquelle nous sommes en
contact direct par nos sens cette
réalité là n'est pas la seule ni la
vraie réalité le monde sensible
platon l'appeler le monde des apparences
parler du monde des apparences
ça signifie qu'il existe un monde au
delà des apparences et ce monde plate on
l'appelle le monde d essence on appelle
également le monde des forme
intelligible essayons d'expliquer ce à
travers quelques exemples concrets
par exemple dans notre monde sensible
nous voyons un tas d'objets naturels qui
sont présents par exemple nous voyons
des arbres autour de nous et tous ces
arbres ont un point commun c'est qu'ils
sont des arbres mais si on les analyse
de près si on les compare on s'aperçoit
qu'aucun de ces arbres n'est semblable à
un autre tous les objets sensibles sont
uniques distincts bien qu on les
regroupe sous le même nom sous le même
terme sous le même concept
ça signifie que derrière chaque arbre
particulier et bien se trouve l'idée
d'arbres l'idée d'arbres autrement dit
un concept qui regroupe la totalité des
arbres matériel qui peuplent notre terre
c'est une idée qui peut paraître assez
bizarre mais pourtant c'est une idée
qu'on emploie très souvent dans le
langage courant
par exemple lorsqu'on parle de l'homme
l'homme avec un grand h
on veut parler de l'être humain en
général de l'être humain générique donc
on veut parler de l'être humain
au delà des individus particuliers qui
représentent le genre humain
et lorsque nous disons l'homme pour
parler de l'être humain en général nous
avons recours à un archétype un
archétype
c'est une idée c'est un concept qui
n'existe pas réellement puisque l'homme
personne ne l'a jamais rencontré dans la
rue l'homme avec un grand h à proprement
parler n'existe pas c'est à dire qu'il
n'existe pas dans notre monde sensible
et pourtant chaque être humain est un
exemple est une illustration est une
image de l'homme avec un grand h
l'homme avec un grand h l'idée d'hommes
c'est l'essence hommes c'est l'homme non
pas en tant que réalité sensible et
particulière mais en tant qu'idée qui
est à la source de tous les hommes qui
existe sur notre planète
le monde sensible pour platon
est une forme dégradée imparfaite et
temporaire d'un monde supérieur qui est
le monde des idées qu'on appelle
également la réalité intelligible quand
nietzsche reproche à platon son son
dualisme bien c'est précisément ça qui
lui reprochent ils lui reprochent de
considérer qu'au delà du monde des
apparences au delà du monde sensible
il existe un monde qui lui n'est pas
soumis aux lois du monde sensible les
lois du monde sensible on les connaît
ce sont les lois de l'espace et du temps
c'est ce qui fait que selon ses lois
une chose par exemple ne peut pas être
là où elle est et ailleurs et c'est ce
qui fait qu'une choses évoluent dans le
temps et n'est jamais semblable à elles
mêmes à chaque seconde qui s'écoule
nous ne sommes pas exactement le même
qu'à la seconde précédente évidemment
cette modification qu'apporte le temps
sur chaque objet sensible elle est
imperceptible à l'oeil nu si je passe
une soirée avec quelqu'un j'aurai beau
l'observer je ne verrais aucun
changement sur lui entre le début de la
soirée et la fin de la soirée il ne se
sera pas passé suffisamment de temps
pour que les changements qui ont affecté
son son physique c'est à dire son
apparence il ne se sera passé à sept ans
pour que ces changements
je puisse les constaté et pourtant ces
changements imperceptible microscopiques
ils existent et ils se produisent de
manière continue c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous les percevons pas
directement à l'oeil nu
septe évolution permanente des choses le
fait qu'une chose ne soit jamais
identique à elle même c'est ce qui
permet à platon de dire que le monde
sensible c'est le monde du devenir le
monde du devenir le monde dans lequel
les choses deviennent si elles
deviennent ça veut dire qu'elles ne sont
pas platon pose strictement la notion de
devenir avec la notion d'être la notion
d'essence par définition lettre est un
vario lettre est stable il est fixe au
contraire le devenir
c'est ce qui va produire du changement
de la transformation de la modification
le monde sans
cible est un monde en devenir c'est un
monde qui évolue chaque chose qui vit
sur cette terre est soumise à la loi de
la transformation à la loi de la
corruption à la loi du devenir
chaque chose et chaque être commence se
déroule et s'achève l'existence humaine
n'échappe pas à la règle
nous tous qui sommes ici nous sommes nés
un jour nous vivons sur une certaine
période de temps est audard mourront
dont notre existence est limitée sur le
plan temporel au cours de cette
existence
nous allons changer nous allons évoluer
l'enfant grandit l'adulte vieilli et le
vieillard meurt et c'est cette évolution
de tout être qui caractérise le monde
sensible le monde du devenir
or pour platon ce monde du devenir ne
peut pas être la seule réalité ils
voient au-delà du monde de devenir une
réalité supérieure dans laquelle tout ce
qui est présent à l'état sensible dans
notre monde existe sous une forme
d'idées c'est à dire existe sous une
forme éternelle est immuable
j'ai donné l'exemple de l'arbre et de
l'être humain tout à l'heure mais on
pourrait prendre cet exemple pour un tas
de choses et c'est ce que fait platon
dans la plupart de ces dialogues puisque
il est toujours à la recherche de la
définition des choses et rejette toute
définition par l'exemple platon nous
explique que lorsque nous définissons de
choses par un exemple nous n'atteignons
pas l'être de la chose nous n'atteignons
pas son essence nous n'atteignons que
l'une de ces images l'une de ses
imitations et pour platon tous les
objets sensibles ne sont que des
imitations des objets réels qui pour lui
sont les objets idéaux les objets qui
appartiennent au monde des idées si bien
que chez platon l'existence le fait de
vivre à l'intérieur de certaines limites
temporelles l'existence les qu'une
imitation de l'idée de vie car l'idée de
vie et au delà de l'espace et du temps
elle est éternelle
revenons un instant sur l'opposition
faite par platon entre les apparences et
les sens d'une chose je disais
alors que tout ce qui vivait sur terre
et est soumis à la loi de la
transformation et à la loi du devenir et
que nous mêmes en tant qu'êtres humains
nous étions témoins de cette de cette
loi du devenir
car nous ne sommes évidemment pas la
même personne aujourd'hui qu'il y a dix
ans et nous ne sommes pas non plus
aujourd'hui ce que nous serons dans dix
vingt ou trente ans et pourtant nous
sommes toujours la même personne
nous sommes toujours la même personne
parce que nous avons le même nous et
parce que nous avons pensons-nous en
tout cas la même identité la même
personnalité peut-être
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose de très
relative puisque la personnalité elle
aussi évolué et que on ne se comporte
pas à 50 ans comme on se comporter à 15
donc cette notion même d'identité
devrait être interrogé et remise en
question mais malgré tout on admet que
au delà de nos évolution personnelle
nous restons la même personne mais si je
fais cette remarque c'est parce que ça
peut nous permettre de comprendre un peu
mieux ce que platon appelle la
connaissance lorsqu'on connaît quelqu'un
on le connaît à partir de ce que cette
personne exprime d'elle et ce qu'elle
exprime à un moment donné n'est pas
forcément la même chose que ce qu'elle
va exprimer dans un autre moment
nous connaissons tous des personnes que
nous avons connue et qui ont changé ou
qui ont en tout cas évoluer sur certains
aspects est ce que nous pensions à
propos de ces personnes à une époque ne
correspond pas forcément à ce que la
personne va rester tout au long de sa
vie nous évoluons tous et ce n'est pas
parce que nous avons une particularité à
un certain moment que cette
particularité fait partie de notre être
ce qui veut dire que connaître vraiment
quelqu'un c'est très problématique car
comment faire la différence entre ce qui
appartient et l'essence de la personne
et ce qui n'est qu'une qu'une propriété
temporaire contingentes qui ne durera
pas qui sera tôt ou tard amené à évoluer
sous l'effet de la loi du devenir
c'est très difficile et d'ailleurs la
plupart des choses que nous estimons
connaître et bien nous les connaissons à
travers ses propriétés qui sont elles
mêmes soumises à la loi du 2
dir pour platon ce que nous pensons
connaître
en fait ce n'est pas la vérité des
choses ce sont leurs apparences
temporaire on ne connaît pas les sens
des choses on connaît l'apparence des
choses à un certain moment et c'est là
que pour platon il y a un vrai problème
de la connaissance
qu'est ce que la connaissance la
connaissance c'est connaître les choses
dans leur invariance dans leur stabilité
c'est connaître les choses au delà de
toute évolution possible lorsque je
prenais l'exemple de l'arbre et de
l'idée d'arbres il est évident que
l'idée d'arbres n'est pas soumise aux
transformations qui affectent les arbres
sensible qu'il ya autour de nous comme
les êtres humains les arbres sont soumis
à la loi de la génération un arbre n'a
pas été là de toute éternité à un moment
donné il est né il est apparu c'est ça
la loi de la génération loi la
génération à laquelle il faut ajouter la
loi de la croissance les choses grand
diesel se développe
et puis les choses se reproduisent êtres
humains se reproduit les végétaux se
reproduisent à travers la floraison la
fructification qui vont donner les
futures graines et enfin les choses
dépérissent et c'est ça qui va rendre
possible la reproduction et la
perpétuation du du cycle de la vie et et
de tout ce qui existe
ce qui veut dire que pour platon aussi
longtemps que nous chercherons à
connaître les choses à travers leur
apparence on ne connaîtra pas à travers
leur essence
or les sens des choses ne se laisse pas
connaître par la perception l'essence
des choses cela se connaître seulement
par la raison la raison étant
précisément ceux qui s'opposent à à nos
sens puisque les sensations sont
toujours relative est elle aussi
temporaires si par exemple je dis qu'une
chose est chaude ou froide si je dis
qu'elle est lourde ou légères grandes ou
petites
c'est un jugement parfaitement relative
puisque si je prends un thermomètre que
je pose la question où commence le show
bien je me retrouve très vite embarrassé
je peux considérer que lorsqu'il fait 45
degrés il fait chaud mais si je met 45
degrés en comparaison avec 800 degrés 45
degrés
froid donc à partir de là toutes nos
connaissances basée sur des sensations
sont nécessairement relative c'est ce
qui faisait que platon et est
l'adversaire principal des sophistes
parmi lesquels protagoras qui soutenait
que l'homme était la mesure de toute
chose
c'est une phrase sous les anneaux
nombreuses interprétations mais si on la
prend dans son sens le plus immédiat sa
signifier que c'est à partir de nos
propres perceptions que nous pouvons
établir la vérité des choses
la tour lui était en totale opposition
avec cette manière de voir précisément
parce qu'il estimait qu' on ne peut rien
connaître si l'on se contente de parler
des apparences d'une chose et de ce que
cette chose renvoie nos perceptions
sensible la connaissance doit porter sur
ce qui est et non pas sur ce qui paraît
elle doit porter sur ce que la chose est
de tout temps et non pas sur ce que la
chose et à un moment donné
la seule chose qui puisse être considéré
comme vrai de manière absolue c'est ce
que je dirai d'une chose et qui se
vérifie de tout temps qu'ils se vérifier
au delà des limites que représente
l'espace et le temps
et pour montrer cette opposition entre
une connaissance imparfaite qui serait
là la connaissance du monde sensible est
la véritable connaissance qui serait là
la connaissance des réalités
intelligible la connaissance des des
idées bien plate on va distinguer ce
qu'il appelle la science et l'opinion
l'opinion étant la fosse connaissance la
connaissance des choses soumise au
devenir alors pour illustrer cette
distinction entre le monde sensible et
le monde intelligible bien on peut faire
référence à ce que platon lui-même nous
a proposé d'en dans la république la
république donc livre dans lequel
plainte on va exposer son allégorie de
la caverne l'allégorie de la caverne
nous dit ceci suppose ont des hommes
dans une taverne retenu prisonnier
depuis leur enfance les mains attachées
obligé de fixer leur regard sur la paroi
qui se trouve au fond de la caverne
ces hommes n'ont jamais connu
l'extérieur de la caverne
ils ne savent pas qu'à l'extérieur de la
caserne il existe un monde
ces prisonniers nous dit platon c'est
nous nous vivons dans une réalité que
nous avons appris à considérer comme
étant la seule vraie
l'it existantes à tel point que nous ne
le remettons jamais en cause et que nous
serions parfaitement incapable
d'envisager l'existence d'une autre
réalité dans cette caserne
derrière les hommes qui regardent de la
paroisse se trouve à muret derrière
lequel se cache un marionnettiste qui
fait défiler des objets puisque le
marionnettiste se trouve derrière les
hommes et que les hommes regardent face
au mur eh bien ils perçoivent les ombres
que ces objets renvoie là encore les
prisonniers n'ont pas la possibilité de
se retourner et de voir d'où viennent
ces ombres donc est ce qu'ils se disent
qu'elles se disent que ces ombres ce
sont des objets ce sont des êtres réels
ce sont des choses qui ont une existence
pleine et entière
il n'imagine pas que ce puisse être
l'ombre d'autres choses puisque pour le
concept dhombres n'a aucun sens pour
qu'il ait un sens il faudrait qu'ils
admettent qu'il y ait une source de
lumière devant laquelle s'intercale des
objets qui produisent ces ombres mais si
on n'a jamais été amené à avoir le
phénomène de l'ombre eh bien on prendra
une ombre pour un objet à part entière
les ombres dont parle platon ce sont les
objets sensibles
c'est la réalité matérielle telle que
nous la percevons quotidien une réalité
que nous pensons être la véritable
réalité une réalité sur laquelle nous
allons parler
nous allons essayer d'en avoir une
connaissance et là on rejoint un petit
peu l'idée de schopenhauer avec le
concept de représentation tout ce que
nous disons dans le monde de la
représentation ne concerne pas la
réalité intime des choses dont nous
parlons la réalité un thiem la volonté
chez schopenhauer
nous n'en connaissons rien nous parlons
de la représentation de la même façon
que les prisonniers de la caverne vont
parler des ombres qui sont des
représentations des objets faisant
obstacle à la lumière maintenant me dit
platon supposons qu'on prenne un de ces
prisonniers qu'on le libère de ses liens
et qu'on le force à sortir de la caverne
or déjà le prisonnier risque d'être un
peu surpris il risque de ne pas
comprendre exactement ce qu'on veut lui
puisqu'on l'a dit ils ne se doutent même
pas qu'en dehors de la caverne il existe
une autre réalité maintenant
ce prisonnier sort de la caverne ce
prisonnier en sortant de la caverne
s'aperçoit donc qu'en réalité les ombres
qu'il percevait sur le mur était la
projection d'objets que l'on faisait
défiler derrière lui il prend conscience
que la réalité qu'ils pensaient être la
véritable réalité la seule réalité
existante était en fait une illusion
était en fait une projection une
représentation il commence à faire la
différence entre la réalité telle qu'on
la voit et la réalité telle qu'elle est
il prend conscience de la différence
entre le monde sensible et le monde
intelligible
il ne connaît pas encore le monde
intelligible mais il sait qu'il existe
maintenant ce prisonnier se trouve hors
de la caverne
il a dû escalader pour sortir de la
caverne
il a dû faire un mouvement d'élévation
qui correspond à ce que platon appel
l'ascension de l'âme vers le vrai
l'ascension de l'âme dans le monde des
idées chez platon on y reviendra dans
une prochaine vidéo
la partie supérieure de l'âme qu'on
appelle l'intellect mais que platon
appelé le nous c'est la partie qui nous
permet de connaître les choses et de
nous élever à la vérité donc l'idée
d'élévation traduit bien cette image
d'un monde supérieur cette image d'un
monde qui est au dessus d'une autre et
jusque auquel nous devons nous hisser au
prix d'un effort à l'effort de penser un
effort d'un thé lections le prisonnier
dehors et sa première réaction c'est de
se couvrir les yeux parce qu'il est
ébloui par la lumière du soleil la
lumière du soleil c'est la vérité et la
vérité nous aveugle
la vérité ne peut pas être regardé en
face lorsqu'on a vécu pendant tant
d'années dans l'obscurité la vérité
quelque chose qui nous agressent est
quelque chose d'insupportable et on
préférerait retourner dans ce monde de
la caverne qui le monde de l'ignorance
que le monde de l'obscurité pour ne pas
avoir à affronter ses rayons seulement
voilà on n'est ce pas le choix ce
prisonnier on lui demande de rester
dehors est affronté le soleil
au bout d'un moment ils commencent à
s'habituer les rayons se font moins vif
il arrive à ouvrir les yeux
il ne peut pas regarder le soleil en
face mais il pour moi supporter sa
lumière
et là ils voient le monde et ils voient
que le monde extérieur existait il
comprend que ce qu'il avait pris jusqu'à
lors pour la véritable réalité n'était
qu un monde d'apparences et d'illusions
il s'aperçoit que les objets auxquels il
avait donné une réalité n'était que des
projections et des représentations
étaient que des imitations d'autres
objets bien plus réel que ce qu'il a pu
contempler et c'est là qu'il comprend
que le monde de la caverne
ce n'est que l'ombre du monde réel le
monde sensible n'est que l'ombre du
monde intelligible
j'aimerais vous donner une une référence
cinématographique qui illustre assez
bien ces différences entre le monde
sensible et le monde intelligible le
monde du faux et le monde devrait le
monde de l'apparence et le monde de
l'essence c'est le film the truman show
avec jim carrey ce film raconte
l'histoire d'un jeune homme truman
l'homme vrai donc qui est à son insu le
personnage central est une émission télé
réalité toutes les missions le concept
de l'émission est basé sur truman
on le voit naître on le voit grandir on
le voit évoluer dans sa vie quotidienne
dans ses relations sentimentales et
truman il ignore qu'il est le personnage
de de cette émission
tout simplement parce que la ville dans
laquelle il habite est un décor de
cinéma dont ils ne voient pas les
coulisses il ne sait pas que toutes les
personnes qu'il côtoie au quotidien sont
des acteurs il a un meilleur ami il a
une femme et là une amie d'enfance et
tout ce qu'il a vécu jusqu'à lors il
avait pu réellement il l'a vécue comme
une expérience véritable est véridique
à aucun moment il ne peut soupçonner
qu'il existe une réalité derrière son
propre monde
et c'est lorsqu'un jour 1 un projecteur
tombe devant lui dans la rue et le fait
que ce soit un projecteur qui tombe est
intéressant du point de vue de la
métaphore puisque le projecteur c'est ce
qui produit une lumière artificielle
précisément c'est ce jour-là qu'il
comprend que quelque chose cloche et
qu'il y a dans sa réalité quelque chose
qui qui sent le faut
qui sans l'illusion et le mensonge et
c'est à ce moment là qui se met en quête
de découvrir le monde qui se trouve au
dessus des apparences c'est à ce moment
là qui se met en quête de vérité et ce
qui est intéressant dans ce film c'est
que truman n'accepte pas immédiatement
l'idée que son monde était un faux monde
puisque ça reviendrait pour nous à
accepter que la réalité dans laquelle
nous évoluons n'est pas une vraie
réalité le fait de dire que ce n'est pas
une vraie réalité ne signifie pas que
notre monde n'existe pas mais pour
platon il ya une différence entre être
et exister lettre n'a pas besoin
d'exister pour être en revanche nous
nous avons besoin de ce monde
intelligible pour exister
l'existence a besoin de l'être
ce rapport qui existe entre les deux
mondes
platon le définit comme un rapport de
participation le monde sensible
participe du monde intelligible
il en est la partie apparente il en est
la partie émergente il en est une
imitation en mouvement le fait qu'on
retrouve dans le monde sensible la loi
des cycles la loi de la génération la
loi de la reproduction donne une assez
bonne idée de ce que représente le
passage du monde intelligible au monde
sensible le monde intelligible et
éternelle
le monde sensible et perpétuelle le
monde intelligible et fixe le monde
sensible et mobile mais tout ce qui se
produit dans le monde sensible est une
image mobile de ce qui est dans le monde
intelligible dans le monde intelligible
il y à la vie et la vie est immobile
dans le monde sensible il y à la vie et
la vie est en mouvement
elles se déroulent dans le monde
intelligible
tous ne forment qu'un dans le monde
sensible c'est la pluralité qui domine
tout et divers tout et variées mais
cette variété des que l'image de l'unité
dans sa forme éclatée et diviser les
êtres que nous sommes sont tous
distincts mais ils sont tous une
parcelle de l'unité dont nous provenons
la vérité elle même
unique dans le monde des idées elles se
rencontrent de manière partielle et
subjectif dans le monde sensible tout ce
qui existe en tant qu'unité dans le
monde intelligible existe en tant que
pluralité dans le monde sensible le
travail du philosophe c'est de ramasser
cette pluralité pour aller au delà pour
accéder à la vérité car la vérité existe
et elle n'est pas de ce monde
[Musique]